All right so you're Ready to get a go [pie] go
I'm going to be Putting links in the Description for Basically all [of] the Parts that you're Going to need as
Well As run Through the Initial Setup Process and Stuff for you guys so uh
You There's Basically two
Major Options Here You Can Either
Get like the Base kit and then Piece Together the rest of the stuff that you need for your go [pie] go or you can
Buy Everything all Together
Now you'll save Yourself About
$50 if You Piece it together and Then Basically Anything if You Already Have Say Raspberry pi or
Some of the other Parts You'll save Yourself even More Money so
To me it's Better to get the base kit and then Piece it together
but you Can
Do what you want the simplest Option Is of Course to just Buy the whole kit but $50 Is a little bit extra?
if you ask me that's a missile Launcher right There
So Anyway I'll put [links] in The Description for all the Parts that
We're Going to be Talking About here They are Amazon Affiliate [links] so if You use them you're Supporting Me in the Channel so
Thanks A lot for Anybody who Does Actually use them
So first of all it the go P-- [Aegyo]
Is Made by dexter Industries [and] We Can come to their Website Click on Robots Here and then click the go P-- [i] go
So Scrolling down you'll See they offer a base Kit and a starter kit and also a Classroom kit [but] we're not
Worried About the Classroom Kit so the Starter kit Is $200 versus the base kit Is
$90 so you can get this and it Comes With Basically it comes With a raspberry Pi
Model B+ the Base Kit The Servo Package and a Distance Sensor so
There's That and Whoops I hit my back Button um
So you can get that or you can get the base kit pieces Together and save Yourself a little bit more Money so Anyways Continuing
Along Here
Step One Would be the go P-- [aegyo] base kit so you can get this here or through dexter Industries Comm
Again if You want to support Me in the Channel you can get it here it's the Same Price
Won't Really Change Anything it's [actually] even Sold by dexter Industries so Anyways There's that so you'll need the base kit
After that You're Going to need a raspberry Pi
[Now] you Can Either get Model B or the Model B+ [I] believe you could get away with the raspberry Pi [too]
But you might have to add some Code in so I'm not
Positive
How Easy that Would be for some of you so if you want to stay safe I would either get
the B or the B plus
Next up you need a microsd Card Now Their image is A 4 Gigabyte, ish Image but as you May
Or May not Know 4 Gigabytes Does not Mean 4 Gigabytes it means about 3.6 or so so if
You want to be Safe I would get at least [8] Gigabytes 8 Gigabyte Sd card Is
$4 so
Might as, well go [with] the 8 you Can find
Sd Card [I] formatted One of my 4 Gigabytes and I did not Have enough Space [for] Their little Custom image so
Just Keep that [in] Mind so i would get at least an 8 I usually get 16 Though and 16 Is
$2.00 More
so There's that as you need Sd Card and then Finally the other must have is
The Edimax Wi-Fi Adapter so These are the Main things that you'll need the Base kit Raspberry [Pi]
Sd Card for the Raspberry Pi and an Edimax Wi-Fi
Adapter One Thing to Note if You get the b+ or a later Raspberry Pi
You'll Need to have an Sd Card that's Actually like it's a Sd adapter for a Micro Sd Card
[ok]
so Keep that [in] Mind Because the B+ and later only Take Micro Sd Cards it Saves A lot of Space and
Also on the older Models the Sd Card Really Stuck out and it was Just Really
Easy to Break it so it's a good
Idea to just go Ahead and get the Micro Sd so you can be compatible With all the pi's
Moving Right Along
That was the edimax Wi-Fi adapter you'll need that?
Then You Have a Distance Sensor now you Can you this Distance Sensor from Two places This is the basic Distance Sensor and as you'll
See, there's, no uh nope
Cords here so if you don't [have] any Jumper Cables
Or, Jumper wires what you're Going to want to do Probably. Is Splurge for the Distance Sensor that dexter Industry sells it's
$19.99 so it's Considerably More
Than The basic Distance Sensor Does The exact Same Thing but
It's a little it has like a little Plug [Here] and it comes With the Cord that you need that has you know the
The Ground The Trigger the Sensor and the Power and So it's Just Really Easy
But if You have some Jumper cables Around I would Just go with this, one it's Way Cheaper
[but] Choose Whichever one You want they don't sell this one on Amazon [so] you'll have to get it Through dexter Industries
Next up Raspberry Pi Camera Module This is so your Robot can See so for example Here
We have uh me doing my lovely tutorial right Now with my coffee, that's on on e at the moment
So i might Pass out at any moment uh
Anyway so you got this this is so you Can Stream and See what your [pi] is doing and all that so that's Really
Useful to Have, also in the later Tutorials, we're Going to be working with open CV
[so] this Is just so you can see what your Robot Sees but With open CV
That'll all be Kind of Behind the Scenes you, [won't] really have to
Worry About that but the Camera Module is really cool to have it is A mere like 25 now
$23 free Shipping so
Cheap and it's Really cool to have so i highly [recommend] the Camera Module if you don't Already have one Anyways
Moving Right Along the Servo Package this is so
Basically You have it here you can
Also See it on my go P-- [I] go here on the Screen this is so you Can Connect your
[Distant] Sensor and your Camera to the Servo and then you Can kind of you Can, swivel Swivel you can
Swivel the Camera Around and Kind of Look Around With your Camera on your Distance Sensor
This is Probably the least mess the Second to least Necessary
Addition To your go P-- i go
[But] I think it's Really cool and for $13 I mean might as
Well so next We have the missile Launcher this is the least Necessary?
But it's, also the coolest Thing that you Can, Add to [it] if you ask me so
Do what You want we're Going to be Covering using?
We will cover using the servo Package here and We will, also cover using the missile Launcher you can
Actually Have your Robot Automatically Fire Missiles at things so
That's Really cool so i highly [recommend] it but it Is $45 Which Is kind of high
But it does Shoot These Things for like 20 feet so that's Pretty cool
Actually [I] Think it Says 25 feet that's the Promise
So Anyway I think it's cool but Probably the least Necessary Thing if You're Needing to save some Money
next up
We have the tutorial Basically so that's all the stuff that you need, We will Have tutorials Covering how to Use all of this Stuff?
Calculating Distances using the Camera, Especially Opencv, We'll be doing some more Advanced tutorials With this Camera Module
The Servo Like I said it's not super Necessary you Can, always Just Turn your Robot you can
Make The Robot Itself Rotate if you need to Look Around so just you can
Keep that in Mind if You want this thing Is pretty cool, we're Gonna Actually?
We're Going to try to have it Automatically Shoot Targets so
So it'll be Kind of cool to have [it] but again you won't Necessarily need it to follow Along
Once You Have your go [pi] go and all your parts the next step is to put it together so
Dexter [Industries] if You go here to Robot Scope I go looking [for] go by go Instructions yep
We are Getting started you'll click on that and
These are all you need to assemble the go pi go you Can click on that and There's an Instructions you Can either get Step-By-Step
Instructions and Kind of Like written Form for the go Pago Servo Package in The Camera but They
Also Have Video Instructions for all of this Stuff so
It's extremely Simple I really Applaud dexter Industries For how simple They Made this go [Pi]
Go I realize it's A lot of little Parts that
We're Kind of Throwing at you but as far as Robotics go this is Really simple to put all this Stuff Together so
That's Really cool, now
After That Once You have it together you want to connect to the go pi go there's A lot of Options and
There's You know Depending on your [Operating] System how, you're going to do this
My personal Preference is to Connect
Via
Ssh now that's Going to entail Usually Plugging in an ethernet Cable like A cat 5 to your [goat] or your Raspberry Pi
[Scanning] for ip Addresses Connecting that Way
[and]
So you Can Either do that
To first Figure out what your ip Address is because you connect you Can Have your Wi-Fi adapter but until you know what the ip
Address Is and then, also until you actually connect to your Wi-Fi Network on your raspberry Pi [you're] not gonna be able to connect Remotely
But Anyway Section 4 Here Connect to the go pi go Really Simple I
Recommend Use Option Number 3 Or Option Number 2 but 3 Is where you're Eventually going to have to get like
There's no Point of Having a Robot if You always have [to] have an your net Cord attached to it so
Um so Definitely I Would go three
I also learned Something new on Windows you can get Bonjour Which is like a printer
Application and You Can Automatically Scan and find your pi and connect to it via Bonjour Which I thought like that's Really cool
I've Never Heard of Anybody doing that so
Um you know for the first Time that you connect to [it] that Makes A lot of sense if You've Never Had to go Through
the Process
[Maybe] you, won't Respect that as. Much but that's Pretty cool
So Anyways you'll Connect it you got to get the ip it at least Initially Somehow
Another Easy Ways is to connect a monitor to it connect your ethernet or your [Cat5] cable Boot up your Raspberry Pi and Usually
When you Finally get to the Login Screen Just A bit above Where you're Going to Log in It'll literally Say where your ip
Addresses so [then] you Can Connect via, Ssh which Is here so like my pi's ip Address Local IS 192 168 0
109 so then from Putty, We Log in that Way?
[so] [then] uh there's that, also if You haven't got to that Point to you're Going to need to
Also install
Like your Operating System to your Raspberry pi [if] you get the kit
It'll Come With A [four] gigabyte Sd Card With it Already on There
If You Buy your Own Sd card you're Gonna have to format [it] and
Install and Mount the image now that sounds Really Complex but it's not and
Actually you Can They Have tutorials on dexter Industries again you Can, also find a really Easy tutorial on
Raspberry Pi's Website but This, One's Good Enough to you've got
Modify your Own Image and
Let's See
I'm looking for [ya] Right here Option if you come to Option number two here Download and use ours if You want to download
Modifiable Whoa, We have Step-By-Step instructions here for?
Mounting The Image so you come Here and again [we've] got it by a Sd or abaya Operating system Say if you're on Pc
You download Their Image cool you extract it cool then use Win32diskimager
Yup and you mount the image Really, Easy Tutorials Just Follow it it's step by Step and That's Exactly how
You're Supposed [to] do it so Easy Enough
Now that [You've] Got [your] operating system at that Point you're Ready to rumble
Actually Start Programming so again I realize that's Kind of A lot, [of] Stuff to Throw at you in One Video
[but] Once You get it all together
You'll find that from here it's Just Smooth Sailing you Just have to Program
[the] Go P-- I go now but Luckily for you there's like a base Kind of Framework or Api Whatever you want to call it
Built Alongside the Go P-- [I] go board so like getting your let's Say you want to Make your go Pay go go Forward
that is as Simple as FWD open Close Parenthesis enter boom your go pie Goes Going Forward right and
So getting it to move is extremely simple [if] You Followed Along our more Advanced A
Robotic Series Here
Then You Probably Remember
Wiring it up, was Kind of a Pain
[and] then Actually
Controlling the H-Bridge to get your Motors Because your Motors go Both Forward and Backwards right
So getting the H-Bridge is Configured and Setup and then you know which which io pins
Do you need to trigger and Send signals to i mean it was it [was] Kind of Confusing
So this Would be like a little bit more of an Advanced Kind of Robotic Series but as far as
Robotics Logic Is Concerned using the go P-- [Aegyo] is incredibly Simple and Definitely Worth Worth your While
It's Really Nice and it's great for Especially Beginners and stuff like that but then you can
Actually Start [Getting] Advanced With it pretty Quick so I
Really Like it so [far] I'm A big fan of the go P-- I go at this Point
so
Anyway that's what you Guys Have to look Forward to what we're Going to do in the next tutorial is get our go P-- [I]
go to
Be Controlled Remotely by us using [our] Keyboard so we'll start off With that we'll Talk about
Autonomy in The Subsequent Video using the Distance Sensor and All that and
Then After That We'll be Diving Into the enamel
Also actually We'll cover how to use the missile launch or to buy your Keyboard Which is Pretty cool
And then after that We'll Talk [about] using the Camera Module
[OpenCV] and All that to Automatically Detect Stuff and all that so OpenCv is Really cool
Because You start Getting Into like Image Recognition and Stuff and so
That's A Really exciting thing and Then getting your
Go Pi go or whatever Robot you're Working with Automatically Detect things and do Things that's Really
Really cool so Anyways that's what you guys have to look forward to if you have Any Questions Comments Concerns
Whatever
Getting your go pi goes Set Up to the point Where at least you can Log, Into your go pi go like This
[Please] Feel free to leave them, Below [I'm] using Putty on Windows and then
Also for the Gui file System I use Wynn Scp i highly recommend winscp
Otherwise if You can Get to this Point then you're Ready to Continue on to the next tutorial so stay tuned Flat